So these are the 12, 12 principles. And
I should say that the 12 principles, um,
like any principles of
framework aren't, um, you know,
don't come from on high on
stone tablets or anything else.
Frameworks are thrown out into the
scientific community to be beaten up and
who'd be ripped apart and put
back together and, and uh,
and to see if they have any
utility or any value. Uh,
and what is useful about
these is that they're,
they've been around for coming on 20
years out there with lots of a discussion
and they are at this
point, widely used. Uh,
and we can talk a lot more about this,
but let's talk about principal one.
It's better to prevent waste than to
treat or cleanup waste after it's formed.
So the reason that it's necessary to
state this is cause the entire history of
environmental protection has been then,
you know,
you're just treat a controlling waste
and all well with the world. Okay.
So that has been the whole,
whole industries have sprouted up to
clean up after wasteful manufacturing
processes. Waste will end
of life. Uh, but there's,
there's an inherent problem with
the create and cleanup waste
issue and one has to do with
the laws of thermodynamics.
Okay. So we talked about, well,
we'll make sure that if, uh,
there, we'll close our, our loops.
There won't be any emissions, there
won't be any, uh, exposure to people, uh,
workers, consumers, there won't be any
exposure, uh, to the air, to the water.
These loops stay closed based on
thermodynamics right up until they don't,
and they dissipate.
And when we're talking about
substances that persist,
that bioaccumulate the build up into our
bodies and the biosphere, the idea of,
well, it's okay if we can create
it, we'll just clean it up.
Becomes, um, an experiment
that we've run for many,
many decades and shown that it
doesn't, uh, it doesn't work
and I'm close to anything I say.
Please feel free to challenge.
But the other issue is that,
does it cost money to
treat or clean up waste?
It has a cost energy. Do you have to
expend energy to separate the waste,
to clean it, to treat it? And it,
does it add performance to a product?
Does it add efficiency to
a manufacturing scheme?
Why have we thought that environmental
issues cost a lot of money for decades?
Because this has largely been
the approach that we've used.
Our approach to dealing with these issues
has largely men that you were going to
have a significant expenditure principle
to synthetic methods should be designed
to maximize the incorporation
of all materials use, uh,
now that are used into the final product.
Basically,
if you're going to put an atom in,
you want it to wind up in your product
and not into your waste stream,
it's concept called Adam economy.
We're going to talk a lot about
it and we're going to, uh,
be able to actually measure what's the
Adam Economy of these transformations.
Principle three,
Rev.
A practical synthetic methods should be
designed to use in generate substances
to possess little or no toxicity to
human health and the environment.
So we captured this.
So you want to use whether it's
your reagents, you're feedstocks,
um,
and all of these transformations that
possessed little or no toxicity to human
health and the environment and toxicity
really is probably better understood as
hazard.
Well,
more generally principle for the
products chemical come products should be
designed to preserve efficacy of function.
So not that you have a very
nice soap, that's, that,
that, uh, doesn't have any toxicity,
but it doesn't work as a self preserve.
The efficacy of function
while minimizing toxicity.
Okay, this is going to be a
large section of this class.
When we started talking
about molecular design,
we start talking about hazard reduction.
This is what we're talking about
on ciliary substances.
There's a whole lot of things
that go into manufacturing.
There are solvents there. Our
separation agents, there's,
there's energy that's put in, uh, to, uh,
to bring about separations
that we'll talk a lot about.
And these can make up a huge percentage
of the waste stream and pharmaceuticals.
It's estimated that 80% of the waste
are the solvents that are used and the
manufacturing process. So we kind
of underestimate this so that they,
there are ways to not only come up with
alternative solvents and other exonerees
that are less toxic, but also ways
to eliminate them. Completely.
Principles six energy,
energy and the nature of its energy
needs to be understood how much embedded
energy is going into the
harvesting or mining. How much, uh,
how much energy is going into the,
the manufacturer, the separations,
the isolation, the purification, and the
nature of that energy. Is it renewable?
Is it a, is it fossil? Is a
depleting principle seven,
a raw material.
This is our feedstocks question.
Should be renewable rather than
depleting wherever the technically and
economically practical, renewable,
renewable, and what kind of timeframe
oils, renewable, they just a few million
years. So not on a geologic timeframe.
We're talking about a human timescale.
If you're,
if you're not able to renew this
on, uh, your, your materials, uh,
on a time frame in there, your
definitionally depleting principle eight,
this is more subtle.
It's, uh, actually, uh,
an order to get from a to B.
Many times you have to go through a
double prime, a prime, a double prime,
a tip triple prime,
and you transform it on your way to to be.
That has been the way for a hundred
years coming up with ways of instead of
going through all of those other
steps that generate all kinds of ways,
he was all kinds of material.
Instead come up with ways
that we can eliminate these,
these steps catachesis we are going to
devote whole focus to Catalin [inaudible]
we'll be discussing what ketalysis is
and the spoiler alert catachesis allows
you to make product with less energy,
less material,
less waste. And there's not a
petrochemical, pharmaceuticals,
specialty chemical company that would
be in business today without it.
Principle 10 products should be
designed so the end of their function,
they do not persist in the environment
and they break down into unoccupied
degradation products. I
didn't say bio degradation,
products, degradation products.
This definition leaves open
that you want to have, you know,
both natural degradation as
well as trigger degradation
so that you can break it
down into building blocks that can
be used for other upcycling purposes.
So there are ways to break down plastics.
For instance,
Donna to the basic
building block monomers,
so that's going to use him as
virgin plastic. Once again, uh,
investigating what this means so that
they don't last forever or build up in our
bodies of the biosphere.
Analytical methodologies
should be developed so that
we can test in real time in
process, in field rather than
as has been done for so long.
After you create the, the contamination
or after you've generated the waste,
you then measure it and say, oops,
look what we have to deal with now.
Realtime analysis and then principal
12 substances and the form of these
substances,
uh,
should be used to minimize the potential
for chemical accidents, including fires,
explosions,
or at least as you don't want to have
pollution prevention and accident
prevention working at opposite goals.
You have to align these so
that accident prevention,
and there are inherent ways that
you can engage in chemical safety.